-Jean-Philippe Pierron,
vous êtes philosophe,
spécialiste
de la question du soin
et de l'éthique médicale,
réflexion qui,
aujourd'hui,
englobe non seulement
les autres hommes,
mais aussi la nature,
les animaux et même la montagne,
puisque votre dernier livre
nous enjoint à "méditer
comme une montagne".
D'autre part, vous êtes croyant.
Je le dis parce que la dimension
spirituelle est importante
dans votre écologie.
Peut-être que, justement,
on peut commencer
par une définition
de ce que vous entendez
par l'écospiritualité.
-Oui, euh...
Je ne m'attendais pas
à une présentation ainsi,
et donc, si on installe
la question de la croyance,
y compris
avec les doutes qui la...
Qui l'habitent et,
comment dire ?
Les incertitudes
et les inquiétudes, en fait,
qui la structurent, c'est comme ça
que je me définirais,
je me définirais plus
comme un cherchant
qu'un croyant,
mais... le...
En fait, l'idée d'écospiritualité,
c'est une manière de dire
que quand on parle
des questions d'écologie,
les enjeux sont souvent
des enjeux de sciences
et il nous faut des savoirs
parce qu'une bonne partie
des enjeux de l'écologie
échappent à nos sensibilités
parce qu'ils sont invisibles,
même s'ils sont très consistants,
que ce soit
les enjeux climatiques
ou l'érosion d'une biodiversité
qu'on ne connaît pas,
donc il y a
des enjeux de savoir
et des enjeux d'action
qui relèvent du champ du devoir,
comme les perspectives éthiques
et politiques, donc la question
de "qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?",
personnellement ou collectivement,
c'est ce que fait
l'écologie politique, mais à côté
de l'écologie scientifique d'un côté
et politique de l'autre,
il y a une troisième dimension
qui est celle du sensible
et du sensible à la fois
dans sa dimension esthétique
et dans sa réception
intérieure
et donc, moi,
j'aurais tendance à tirer
la question de l'écospiritualité
de ce côté en disant
que la transition écologique,
qu'est-ce qu'elle nous fait ?
Eh bien, elle nous fait précisément
et elle nous fait intérieurement.
Elle nous fait du point de vue
de ce qu'elle a comme impact
sur nos subjectivités.
On les connaît, ces impacts,
déjà du côté
de la psychologie,
on parle aujourd'hui
d'écopsychologie,
une des formes possibles
d'écoanxiété,
mais plus profondément,
elle impacte aussi le sens même
de ce que signifie pour nous
être vivant sur terre,
et donc, au sens large,
sans que ce soit affilié
à une tradition religieuse,
la notion d'écospiritualité,
qui est une catégorie
transreligieuse,
si on veut,
en tout cas
non immédiatement affiliée,
elle est une manière de dire
que les questions d'écologie
sont aussi des questions
d'intériorité qui interrogent
comment celles-ci
peuvent se repenser
dans leur rapport
à l'en-dehors
et à leurs interdépendances
avec tous les êtres,
tous les vivants,
y compris des êtres non vivants,
puisqu'une montagne...
Enfin, c'est toute la question.
-Vous proposez même une méthode :
l'écobiographie.
C'est quoi, une écobiographie ?
-Ca part de l'idée de,
quand nous répondons
à la question "qui suis-je ?",
que disons-nous ?
Nous racontons des histoires,
comme disait Hannah Arendt
à sa façon,
et donc, nos identités sont,
pour le dire autrement, narratives.
"Si dire, c'est raconter,
"que racontons-nous de nous
et que taisons-nous ?"
Et donc, l'idée d'écobiographie,
c'est de dire
que la plupart de nos biographies
sont souvent des biographies
à notre insu
ou délibérément officielles,
une sorte
de curriculum vitae
qui dit
ce qu'il serait bon de dire
parce qu'on pense que c'est ça
qui nous définit vraiment
alors qu'il y a une dimension cachée
de nos biographies dans nos sociétés
dont l'écobiographie, à sa manière,
peut être l'expression,
c'est-à-dire que
ce qui nous constitue,
c'est aussi
toute une infinité de liens,
je dis "interdépendances",
avec des êtres humains, bien sûr,
mais des êtres
autres qu'humains,
des milieux, une source,
un arbre,
des animaux,
des ambiances,
une qualité de l'air,
une ambiance sonore, etc.,
qui contribuent
à définir qui nous sommes.
Je prends souvent un exemple
pour illustrer ça,
même dans le langage très gris
de l'administration
qu'est par exemple
un numéro de Sécurité sociale.
Moi, dans mon numéro de Sécurité
sociale, il y a un 54
qui signifie ou qui renvoie
à la Meurthe et à la Moselle,
comme deux rivières
sans lesquelles,
d'une certaine façon,
je ne serais pas qui je suis.
C'est pas des grands fleuves,
ils sont pas grandioses,
c'est pas l'Amazone
ou c'est pas le Rhin,
mais ma biographie
se raconte
à l'égard de son milieu
et avec ce milieu,
donc l'idée d'écobiographie,
c'est de dire que nous écrivons
qui nous sommes,
individuellement
ou collectivement,
parce que l'écobiographie,
elle a un sens intime,
mais elle peut aussi avoir
une signification politique,
c'est la question
de la biopolitique,
donc l'écobiographie, c'est dire,
au fond, que pour honorer
à sa juste profondeur
les sujets que nous sommes,
eh bien, il y a peut-être
un travail de reconnaissance à faire
à l'égard de tous ces liens
qui nous font être
et qui sont nos dépendances
non nécessairement aliénées
à l'égard, effectivement,
de nos milieux.
Je préfère cette notion
à celle d'environnement
parce que, précisément,
c'est pas autour de nous,
nous sommes tressés avec eux,
c'est ça qui est
dans cette idée
d'écobiographie.
-Cette question du lien,
elle est intéressante
parce qu'elle pousse
certains écologistes à minorer,
voire à exclure
la place de l'homme.
Pour vous, l'écologie
n'est pas un antihumanisme.
Comment s'articule
ce "je" au "nous" ?
C'est le titre
de l'un de vos ouvrages.
Comment on articule un je au nous
sans renoncer au je ?
-Oui, alors, c'est un enjeu,
je crois, qui est décisif.
-Effectivement,
à un moment donné,
on a pu vouloir opposer
humanisme et écologie
en disant qu'il y avait là
une manière de dilution
de tous les grands acquis
à la fois des Lumières,
des grandes pensées d'émancipation
à l'égard de ce qui nous aliène
et ce qu'on appelle "la nature"
peut aussi être aliénante.
Il ne s'agit pas de minorer,
là aussi,
que les milieux...
Enfin, la nature
n'est pas une gentille maman
ou papa.
Il ne s'agit pas
de penser moins l'humain,
mais de le penser mieux,
et donc, en fait,
penser nos appartenances,
ce n'est pas
nous aliéner nécessairement.
Il y a un défi qui est,
d'une certaine manière,
de relire notre propre héritage,
à l'égard de la pensée
des Lumières en particulier,
mais plus largement encore,
ce défi, c'est de penser ensemble
l'autonomie et l'appartenance.
C'est qu'en fait, pour penser
notre autonomie de sujet,
qui se conquiert aussi
dans des formes d'émancipation
à l'égard de tout ce qui peut
nous aliéner :
les pratiques sociales,
certaines formes de traditions,
mais aussi
des enfermements
dans des "terroirs",
eh bien, pour penser l'autonomie
est-ce que le prix à payer,
c'est celui de l'arrachement ?
Il me semble, en fait,
sans forcément faire une apologie
des racines, je me méfie
de ce langage des racines,
Steiner disait : "Les hommes n'ont
pas de racines, ils ont des jambes",
et je me méfie de ce langage
parce que, très vite, on voit
comment il peut être
pauvrement identitaire,
il caricature ce que c'est
qu'une identité, en définitive,
eh bien, donc, penser de façon
plus profonde et articulée
l'autonomie
et l'appartenance,
c'est dire, effectivement,
que nos attachements...
sont des liens
et que ces liens
ne sont pas nécessairement
des liens qui nous aliènent,
mais ça peut être
des liens qui nous libèrent,
pour oser un peu
ce paradoxe.
Nous avons un peu peur
de la dépendance.
Nous sommes dans des cultures
où la dépendance est tout de suite
pensée comme une aliénation,
ou possiblement une aliénation,
alors qu'en fait,
elle est le sens
intégré en nous de nos ouvertures
à ce que sans quoi on ne saurait
être qui nous sommes,
donc il s'agit aussi de repenser
une conception ajustée
de la dépendance
dont la catégorie
de vulnérabilité,
de ce point de vue-là,
est une expression,
puisque la vulnérabilité
n'est pas qu'un défaut
qui annonce des défaites,
elle est aussi
une capacité d'ouverture
à se laisser blesser
par ce qui nous fait être.
-De façon littérale, vous avez
travaillé en soins palliatifs.
On parle de la vulnérabilité,
de la dépendance,
est-ce que vous pourriez
nous en livrer l'expérience
et peut-être les conclusions
que vous avez pu...
-Sur la question
des soins palliatifs,
pour moi, avant d'être
une spécialité médicale,
c'est une pensée à nouveaux frais
de la compréhension que nous avons
de la vulnérabilité.
De fait, en fin de vie,
on a l'impression
que c'est la forme, c'est une
des formes de la vie humaine
ou l'entrée dans la dépendance,
dans la très grande dépendance,
c'est la porte ouverte
à la fin de l'humain
alors qu'en fait,
c'est le lieu où s'expérimente
le fait que
ce qui nous fait tenir
comme vivant parmi les vivants,
ce sont des liens,
donc dans l'expérience
de cette vulnérabilité
la plus grande
qui est celle
de l'alitement définitif
avant ces derniers jours
qui font la vie, eh bien,
il s'agit encore
d'y être vivant
et de lutter.
Paul Ricoeur disait :
"Ne confondons pas l'agonisant
avec le mourant",
ne projetons pas sur la fin de vie
le fait qu'il n'y aurait
plus rien à vivre.
Il y a des choses à vivre
et ce qui s'y exauce,
c'est le fait
que c'est tous ces liens
qui nous constituent dans l'être,
bien qu'ils s'en trouvent exaucés,
et tous ces liens, y compris ceux
avec les autres, bien sûr,
nos proches, les soignants,
mais aussi les liens
avec les milieux.
Ce qui m'intéresse
dans les soins palliatifs,
c'est de travailler
sur les milieux de soins
et parmi ces milieux, il y a
l'architecture, les paysages,
les formes du vivant non humain.
C'est intéressant de voir que,
dans les hôpitaux,
les animaux sont bannis,
pas dans les unités
de soins palliatifs
parce que les vivants
autres qu'humains
nous rendent vivants,
viennent nous chercher encore,
viennent nous stimuler.
Ca peut être une minuscule
sauterelle qui rentre
indument dans la chambre
un soir d'été,
dans la chambre de ce malade,
ça peut être la qualité d'un soir
et d'une lumière
d'un soir d'été ou d'hiver,
tous ces éléments-là, en fait,
sont l'expression,
effectivement,
de nos êtres vulnérables,
c'est-à-dire ouverts
à ce qui vient les susciter,
et donc, en ce sens-là,
ça n'a rien à voir avec la mort
et je crois qu'on est en train
de changer ça, de découvrir
que la question de ce qui se joue
en soins palliatifs,
c'est des questions de la vie
et pas de la mort.
Ca interroge
sur ce qui nous rend vivants.
Ca peut être surprenant
que je fasse
ce pont entre des questions
d'écologie d'un côté
et de médecine de l'autre
alors qu'en définitive,
je crois que
c'est venir interroger
ce que signifie pour nous
être vivant
ou plus exactement
être existant.
-Est-ce que
c'est la question du soin
qui vous a mené
à la question écologique
ou est-ce que tout ça
s'est fait de concert ?
Comment ça s'est noué
dans votre propre écobiographie ?
-Oui, oui, euh...
Oui, c'est toujours un...
Il y a à la fois des choses insues
qui montent doucement en concept,
comme on dit, mais...
j'ai commencé par travailler
sur les questions
de qu'on appelait
et qu'on appelle toujours
la bioéthique
avec un étonnement parce que
dans "bioéthique"...
Le radical de "bioéthique",
il ouvre à tout ce qui est vivant
et les fondateurs de la bioéthique,
Potter en particulier...
C'est pas le Harry, hein,
c'est un médecin américain.
Il... Il insiste,
quand il parle de bioéthique,
sur l'idée qu'il y a un lien
autour de la question du vivant,
entre le vivant humain,
le vivant non humain,
l'animal et le vivant végétal.
C'est qu'en fait,
la bioéthique n'est pas
qu'une éthique médicale,
mais, effectivement,
ce qu'on en a fait depuis 35 ans,
c'est essentiellement
une valorisation
des enjeux d'éthique médicale,
mais d'une éthique médicale
sans milieu,
d'une éthique médicale
où elle pensait le vivant
indépendamment de
et à un moment,
ce qui m'a frappé,
il y a deux choses qui m'ont frappé
dans les questions de bioéthique,
la première, c'était de découvrir
que les techniques qu'on déploie
dans l'assistance médicale
à la procréation
sont des techniques qui sont issues
des biotechnologies animales,
des techniques d'insémination
artificielle pour les ovins,
les bovins, mais mises au point
par l'INRA,
autrement dit, les biotechnologies
du vivant sont transfrontalières
entre le vivant non humain
et le vivant humain
et le second élément,
c'était le grand écart
entre l'éthique médicale
concernant
ce qu'on appelle pauvrement
"la médecine somatique",
parce qu'au fond, notre médecine
est construite sur un dualisme
dont elle a du mal à se dépêtrer,
d'une certaine façon,
mais quand on est en psychiatrie,
ce qui est atteint
par la maladie,
c'est la possibilité de se tenir là,
c'est la question
du "dasein",
comme on dit,
dans notre jargon de philosophe,
la question d'"être là".
La maladie tient, ici, dans le fait
que j'arrive pas à y être, hein.
Soit dans l'enfermement
presque sidéré
d'un blottissement qui devient
une espèce de pétrification de soi.
Soit dans le langage
de la grande errance, du vagabond...
de l'"automate ambulatoire",
comme on disait au 19e s.,
pour parler
des malades errants,
qui cherchaient
à se rythmiciser en marchant.
La psychiatrie est
très attentive
au fait que la maladie mentale
attaque notre présence au milieu,
et donc, il s'agit de travailler
non pas sur les supports,
mais au fait que nos milieux
ne sont pas des supports
sur lesquels nous sommes posés,
mais sur des interdépendances,
qui nous suscitent, nous réveillent.
Donc, c'est comme ça
que j'y suis arrivé.
Je suis arrivé
à la jonction
entre la question de l'écologie
et celle de la médecine,
en découvrant - c'est ce que dira
Guattari, à sa manière,
qu'il n'y a pas d'écologie
environnementale
sans écologie sociale,
et il n'y a pas d'écologie sociale
sans écologie psychique,
donc il faut articuler les trois.
D'où ma perplexité,
qui est de me dire
qu'une grande structure
comme le Conseil consultatif
national d'éthique,
pour lequel j'ai à la fois
beaucoup d'intérêt et de respect,
d'admiration,
n'a jamais, encore, à l'exception
peut-être de la COP21,
travaillé de façon centrale
sur l'articulation
entre les questions de santé
et d'écologie
autrement qu'à partir
du modèle
de ce qu'on appelle
le "facteur environnemental".
-La bioéthique, justement,
vient peut-être de ce divorce
ou de ce dualisme
que vous avez énoncé
entre corps et esprit,
ou un divorce entre science et vie,
en tout cas l'idée que la science
serait un domaine séparé,
et qui appelle, du coup,
l'obligation de la traduire.
Alors, c'est ce que vous faites
précisément, dans l'écobiographie,
mais c'est vrai
que, peut-être...
Comment pourrait-on faire
pour arriver
à faire en sorte
que la science nous parle ?
Quelle faculté faut-il convoquer ?
L'imagination ?
Comment ramener la science
sur terre,
pour qu'elle parle à tous ?
-A mon avis,
il y a des enjeux qui sont liés
à sa structuration,
et puis, donc, à la conscience
que, finalement,
le type de structuration des savoirs
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui,
qui est donc la division des savoirs
"en silos", comme on dit,
des sections
de spécialisation,
en fait, qui fabrique
des grands spécialistes,
alors qu'il nous faudrait penser
des enjeux transversaux.
Il y a un enjeu,
à mon avis majeur,
qui est en train de se faire,
d'ailleurs :
repenser l'université
dans la division des savoirs.
Nous avons fait
le modèle universitaire
que nous connaissons
sur le modèle humboldtien,
et ce modèle
est en train d'exploser,
parce que la partition
sciences de la nature
et sciences humaines, on voit bien
qu'elle n'est plus éclairante.
Les problèmes d'écologie
sont des enjeux
à la fois de sciences humaines
et des enjeux de géosciences,
par exemple.
Les catastrophes dites "naturelles"
ne sont plus toutes naturelles.
Mais donc, il y a la question
de repenser
comment nous articulons les savoirs,
et aujourd'hui,
il y a un autre enjeu,
qui est quels usages sociaux
nous faisons de la science.
C'est le sens
de la question,
que j'entends...
-Les deux !
-C'est ça ?
-Vous répondez
dans les deux dimensions.
-C'est ça. Et donc,
sur ce second aspect, moi aussi
je suis assez... Jean-Pierre Dupuy
faisait cette observation,
dans un livre,
"Le catastrophisme éclairé" :
"Comment se fait-il
"que nous n'arrivons pas à croire
ce que nous savons ?"
donc, ce divorce, cette dualité
entre ce que nous savons,
ce que nous apprennent nos sciences,
dans leur diversité,
est-ce que nous devons faire,
il y a un gap.
Donc, c'est la question
de la dimension contre-intuitive.
Mon travail, ce que j'essaye
de faire, se love là.
C'est de voir comment faire
pour qu'une information,
dans ce qu'elle a de conquis,
de construit,
de très élaboré,
mais aussi de très abstrait,
parce qu'elle veut se formuler,
justement
dans le langage
de la neutralité axiologique.
Donc, comment faire
pour que le langage très rigoureux
de la science
donne des informations,
nous rejoigne
dans la singularité
de nos histoires.
Donc, c'est comment faire
pour qu'une information
devienne un événement.
Ce n'est pas nécessairement le cas,
on le voit bien : une notification,
sur un smartphone,
c'est une information,
pas encore un événement.
Donc, le passage passe, pour moi,
sur la question du sensible.
C'est la question, en fait,
de laisser retentir une information,
pour qu'elle ait la chance
de devenir une histoire.
Et, là, sans vouloir
les instrumentaliser,
c'est là que les enjeux éthiques
et politiques sont centraux,
car ce sont des opérateurs
de traduction,
d'une certaine manière,
mais plus particulièrement,
le rôle
que jouent les arts.
Dans la diversité
de leurs expressions,
les arts, en fait,
sont des manières de donner
une chair sensible...
Il ne s'agit pas
de les instrumentaliser,
il ne s'agit pas de faire d'eux
les commentateurs
ou les servants
de l'activité scientifique,
mais il y a, en fait,
dans les activités artistiques,
dans la pluralité
des langages artistiques,
une force, en fait,
singulière,
parce qu'elle est
singularisante.
Je pourrais le dire comme ça :
le discours de la science
est un discours
qui cherche l'exactitude.
Le discours des arts
cherche la rectitude,
et notamment la rectitude
de l'image juste.
Ce qui permet à une information
de devenir, pour moi, un événement,
c'est précisément la médiation
de l'image, des images,
d'où le rôle de la fonction éthique
de l'imagination.
Si la question de l'imagination
m'intéresse,
c'est parce que l'imagination
n'est pas que la folle du logis
qu'on a voulu
si longtemps voir,
elle a un double visage,
une double dimension :
elle est à la fois
une capacité
de venir travailler nos affects,
par les images, intérieurement,
donc, en fait, de contribuer
à nous augmenter intérieurement,
dans la pluralité
des images possibles,
car les images
que travaillent les arts,
elles peuvent être joyeuses,
tristes,
elles peuvent être glorieuses
ou aller du côté
des choses un peu opaques
et, donc, de ce qui fait
que nos vies sont nos vies.
Donc, il y a cette dimension
d'intensification.
Mais il y a, ensuite,
une dimension prospective.
J'aime bien dire que les images
qui nous habitent
sont aussi des images
qui nous habilitent.
Ce qui nous habite intérieurement
- je l'évoquais, en commençant,
tout à l'heure : il y a, en moi,
peut-être, de Meurthe-et-Moselle,
une qualité de rivière,
et les grès des Vosges
sont des éléments
qui me structurent assez
pour que je puisse dire
que je suis de là,
d'une certaine façon,
mais en même temps,
ce qui m'habite intérieurement,
m'habilite extérieurement,
car ça prépare, ça nous suscite
dans nos capacités.
Quand je m'autorise
le droit de rêver,
je me prépare aussi à agir,
donc c'est comment
on passe du poétique
à l'éthique et au politique.
Il ne s'agit jamais, pour moi,
d'instrumentaliser le poétique,
mais de lui laisser
sa chance,
pour permettre, justement,
à cette capacité, ce néologisme,
comme sujet capable,
sur le plan individuel ou collectif.
-Le problème des images,
c'est qu'elles sont fortement
concurrencées par pléthore d'images
qui nous arrivent,
sur les écrans, sur les réseaux,
et ce ne sont pas forcément
des images permettant de penser,
il y a une sorte
de saturation
qui empêche peut-être même
l'imagination.
Comment on fait pour arriver
à se prémunir,
par l'imaginaire et l'imagination,
de l'image, justement ?
-Oui, oui.
C'est
un des défis du temps.
C'est le défi
de ce qu'on peut appeler, presque,
la "lassitude compassionnelle",
au temps
de la surdiffusion d'images.
Donc, c'est déjà
un vieux problème, en fait,
que soulevait Walter Benjamin,
en son temps :
en fait,
quand on est à l'ère
de la reproduction infinie
des images,
eh bien celles-ci passent,
elles ont précisément le statut
d'informations,
et pas d'événements.
Je lisais, récemment, que,
sur nos téléphones portables,
on "scrolle" des kilomètres d'images
par jour,
et combien nous affectent ?
C'est peut-être une posture
de philosophe plus vieux, peut-être,
qu'il n'y paraît.
C'est-à-dire que, en fait...
Je crois, en fait, qu'il y a
un enjeu qui est d'abord éthique,
mais qui, je pense,
est aussi politique.
Cet enjeu éthique,
c'est comment,
précisément, comme individu,
je me laisse la chance,
ou pas, de me laisser travailler
par les images qui me traversent.
Ca peut être un choix.
Je peux élire,
au long de la journée, me dire :
"Quelle image je retiens
de cette journée,
"qui est suffisamment consistante ?"
Mais ça veut dire
comment on aide les individus
à pouvoir avoir
cette consistance intérieure,
de dire :
"C'est peut-être,
pour moi, le choix
"de ne pas simplement
me laisser envahir
"par une quantité d'images,
mais d'en élire une",
qui soit heureuse ou pas,
c'est pas la question.
Ce qui fait que,
pour moi,
c'est là que l'enjeu
n'est pas que personnel.
Il y a un discours de sagesse.
C'est pourquoi je dis
que c'est un discours
qui peut paraître
un peu vieillot, de dire qu'il y a
la question d'une réforme de soi.
Ceci dit, j'en suis persuadé :
cette dimension est importante.
Mais il y a
un enjeu politique :
quel type de société
nous fabriquons,
lorsque,
d'une certaine manière,
nous encourageons la confusion,
chez nos concitoyens,
entre leurs désirs
et leurs envies ?
Pour moi, la société de l'image,
qui est fortement marquée
par une puissance
de l'industrie de l'image,
c'est-à-dire
d'un marché de l'image,
il flirte, j'allais dire,
sur la ligne équivoque
du désir d'être profond
et de l'envie.
De telle sorte qu'on finit
ne sachant plus vraiment faire
la frontière entre une envie
et un désir,
et on finit par croire
qu'être abreuvé
par ce torrent d'images,
c'est ce qui viendrait nous
"nourrir" intérieurement.
Là, il y a
une responsabilité politique.
Quand on évoquait,
il y a quelques années,
l'idée de ce qu'on fait
à la télé,
si ce n'est offrir du temps
disponible pour Coca-Cola,
c'est une question qu'il faut
re-poser aux réseaux sociaux.
On voit bien la question que ça pose
pour les plus jeunes d'entre nous.
Quand on est né
avant les réseaux sociaux,
on a une expérience de ce que c'est
que le retentissement profond
et lent des images.
Mais pour les plus jeunes,
quelle chance on leur laisse
de pouvoir aussi n'être
pas simplement sidérés,
mais habités par des images.
Là, la question est politique.
-C'est le rôle du philosophe,
aujourd'hui ?
Que d'enseigner ça ?
Que de prêter attention à ?
Que d'accompagner, peut-être,
des étudiants,
car c'est aussi
un métier de transmission ?
Comment définir
le rôle du philosophe,
dans notre société,
aujourd'hui ?
-Je pense que nous,
les philosophes, on est des...
Je me définis
souvent comme une éponge :
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est d'essayer
d'être présent à mon présent,
et à l'air
ou à l'eau du temps,
et ensuite de trouver
les bons endroits
où ceci puisse se faire,
ou ça puisse être partagé
et évoqué avec d'autres.
Donc, pour moi,
le rôle du philosophe
n'est pas d'être un idéologue.
Je n'ai pas du tout envie
d'avoir à dire aux autres
ce qu'ils devraient penser,
donc, je me méfie beaucoup
du philosophe idéologue,
producteur d'une sorte
de prêt-à-penser.
Donc, ça interroge ce que sont
les bons endroits où intervenir.
Donc, je considère
quand a une responsabilité.
Mes collègues brésiliens
m'avaient alerté là-dessus,
car j'étais
un universitaire français,
donc, la neutralité axiologique,
on connaît, en France,
mais ils disaient :
"Que tu le veuilles ou non,
"tu es un leader d'opinion."
Que faisons-nous
de notre responsabilité ? Donc,
c'est de trouver les lieux
où ceci se déploie.
Donc, ce qui me désole,
c'est que les partis politiques
ne sont plus beaucoup des espaces
où il est possible de pouvoir encore
élaborer une pensée
lente et patiente
pour aborder
des questions complexes.
Les églises ne le font plus trop
non plus, dans un sens.
Mais c'est intéressant que,
en milieux associatifs
et en festivals d'idées,
ce sont des espaces réjouissants
de ce qui se vit en France,
car ce sont des espaces
pré-politiques,
où on peut,
de façon lente,
élaborer le monde qui vient,
dans l'impatience du concept,
mais dans la rigueur du concept.